la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
barbier monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre j'y associe
mon collègue alain moyne bressand
monsieur le premier ministre m
hier nous fêtions 14 juillet la prise de
la bastille un acte qui fit prendre
conscience à la monarchie de la gravité
de la situation de la france en 1789
françois hollande retranché dans son
palais de l'elysée en at il tiré les
conséquences
aucunement dans son interview
seul son autosatisfaction était évidente
écoutent ils les français écoutent ils
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui souffrent
sûrement pas la preuve
pas un mot pas un geste en direction de
l'agriculture et des agriculteurs
pourtant je vous l'assuré chers
collègues colère gronde dans nos
campagnes
issue d'une circonscription rurale où
toutes les filières sont représentées et
rencontrant régulièrement les
agriculteurs je peux vous dire que rien
ne va plus
les agriculteurs souvent les plus jeunes
sont étranglés est prise au piège des
prix qui baissent et des charges qui
augmentent comme les contraintes
administratives
il y à la filière du lait qui est en
urgence avec la fin des quotas et des
prix au plus bas mais aussi la viande
les fruits et même les céréales sont
aujourd'hui menacés alors que
l'agriculture représente une part
importante de nos exportations
les trésoreries des exploitations sont
au plus bas des manifestations de
désespoir se multiplient la demande des
agriculteurs est simple il vous demande
monsieur le premier ministre de faire
respecter les accords du 17 juin signée
par votre ministre de l'agriculture il
vous demande de faire respecter par la
grande distribution et les industriels
une juste répartition des marges
bénéficiaires
il vous demande d'intervenir auprès de
l'europe pour que cette crise soit
endiguée
il vous demande simplement de pouvoir
vivre avec leur famille de leur travail
les entendre et vous monsieur le premier
ministre vous vous réveillerez vous un
matin en sursaut en vous disant mon dieu
c'est une révolution
merci la pole est un monsieur jean marie
le guen mini chargé des relations avec
le parlement
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous
connaissez la règle c'est le
gouvernement qui décide le bénisse qui
apporte la réponse
voilà sur le député mollé coûte
maintenant aller et on vous a dit
pourquoi le ministre de l'agriculture
n'était pas là aujourd'hui
voilà il vous plaît monsieur le député
mesdames l âme et messieurs les députés
le coup d envoi interrogations en
question mais un certain nombre de
points qui sont effectivement au coeur
de l'action du gouvernement qu'il
s'agisse de l'action à bruxelles qu'il
s'agisse dans la réorientation de la pac
qu'il s'agisse de des relations avec la
grande distribution
qu'il s'agisse de la nécessité de
réorganiser nos filières tout ça pour
maintenir les prix oui monsieur le
député depuis des mois et des mois
stéphane le foll rené en arche tous les
points que vous aviez négligé depuis des
années sur tous ces sujets vous n'aviez
jamais prévient prix légers l'élevage
dans la pac nous l'avons fait vous aviez
laissé avec la lme le pouvoir à la
grande distribution
nous sommes intervenus le ministre s'est
impliquée très directement et avec la
loi hamon nous avons réorienté les
rapports de force entre les éleveurs et
la grande distribution
nous intervenons régulièrement sur les
prix et nous baissons les charges
monsieur le député ce que vous n'avez
pas fait bref nous avons un chantier
d'autant plus difficile que vous ne
l'avez jamais pris en charge pendant des
années 6 me